pour cette soirée le moment mais j'ai
pas entendu la tonne qui jouait pendant
que j'ai raté puis je pense que ce
serait important que mon déjeuner il la
remette pour que vous puissiez du traité
et 21 secondes de la fin s'il vous plaît
bah tu arrives dans le fond là ce que ça
faisait sept ans à français c'est que je
n'ai pas qu'un monde me voyais pas ce
qui est un membre pas comprendre si je
pense que ça a aidé écrit bien qu est ce
que je vis depuis toutes ces années là
dans le fond oui je marche beaucoup
pas de temps à temps et comme on dit
mais c'est quand moïse marche
j'aimerais bien ce que le monde m'a
gardé yeux mais ils ont un point
d'interrogation dans la phase qui m'a
gardé peep-toe et si je changerais pas
ce jour l'allemand noter si c'est comme
ça qu'ils m'ont trompé et ce
questionnement issa photo ga ce qui se
passe mais là tout d'abord j'aimerais
quand même remercier luc addor passer un
moment au ft avant intel pour ce soir
certains d'entre vous il quand même vous
connaissez des jours où vous m'avez
parce en train de marcher dans la ville
d'eaux minérales de ces week mart qui
marchent croche expo nikolic
sérieusement non ces débats rose puis
j'ai 23 ans et même avant une mise en
station et vous sortant du hockey de
toute manière vous avez vu que vous
aviez pas le choix fameux vous ou vos
jeux puis essaie d'imaginer une
installation où vous l'avez matin à la
télé et à la radio
stephen harper a pris possession de
toutes les postes clés
les ascquois c'est dépassé pis là il y
annonce que les canadairs est en guerre
contre les états unis
sauf que qu'est ce que vous devez savoir
c'est que les états unis ayant 87 mille
soldats alors que le canada ne sommes à
3000 à merveille qui n'entrave ou parce
que les cadavres ont rapporté 7 bien
accueilli jean louis xii
merci
j'ai quasiment goût de vous fournir sur
un nom oui j'ai eu la malchance de ne
pas trouver par un autre mobile
alors que je fais du vélo puis j'ai été
diagnostiqué avec un traumatisme
cranio-cérébral ça va c'est quoi son un
tcc ça va c'est une commotion mais pays
c'est ton cerveau qui va gagner un peu
partout dans ta boîte crânienne qu'elle
me frapper le tout roulait dans le même
sens - tac mon corps ainsi que mon
cerveau on était valable car le toit des
sites freiner mais mon corps était
proche rival à vin avec mon cerveau j'ai
pas la menace ait marre annoncé sur le
banc la vue qui est elle me dit qu'elle
était certaine que je pensais de côté du
moment qu'elle m'a aperçu étendu sur le
banc de la rue ben elle a appelé du
moment que mes vieux bahut
qu'est-ce qu'on m'annonce que j'ai je
trouve à l'hôpital
elle a appelé quatre fois elle à
l'hôpital pour être certain intérêt à
voir une équipe prête à mieux prendre
soin de moi ce sera à mon chalet ça
prend absolument les miens alors que
sarah a pris 15 minutes à +27 tromper
d'être allé jusqu'à saint roch de
bellecombe avant de revenir à syntoniser
bellecombe rouge était une fois
l'hôpital j'ai possédé scam et j'ai été
transféré par avion un blanc-seing
morial dre la nuit par un style mais pas
autres sont partis pour moyens là en
voiture qui est un bâtisseur pas
d'étiquette que sade et va se réveiller
demain matin et puis vendée salut à tous
j'ai eu à passer cannes - amiens moyens
un obstacle ministre et habitations je
suis néanmoins puis je me sens tu
apprécies tu es avec tous les messages
que j'avais vu sur facebook
longue d'une dizaine terre bouge ta
souris bien vite liquide vient nous
faire qu'à 20 d'évoquer c'est bon là
mais tu es une femme mes amis union
union vu la sévérité demi bla sommet
c'est de là que pas mal de ses amis dans
son domaine des connaissances résume la
fin un nouveau sac d'amis mais c'est
plus jeunes parce que taymour
mallevialle arrêté belle alors à
continuer c'est certain qu'un
inconsciemment j'ai vécu départ a pas de
me retrouver seul au monde n'a pas un
pas deux pour ne pas aimer par ce jeu
qu'à moi j'aime puis on entend même pas
ici de la part de celle jugée parce que
peu importe que mathieu tués dans le
monde le monde ils vont juger de mon il
juge sa savoir c'est quoi un tcc ça
savoir douche douche parti aujourd'hui
c'est bien beau mais je suis parti de où
exactement
la réponse est plus imagée que je peux
donner à ses débuts mon père croyait
voir m'attendent parler à son arrivée à
mort yann moix y entrer ce soir je suis
d'abord parler mais deux mois après
l'accident j'étais un pack à madame anne
debout encore ça m'a pris un mois et 5
jours avec un mot sort de ma bouche puis
je disais babayan orthophonie ce parce
que je détestais l'orthophonie
j'ai marché 1950 le mettre là dany mais
ça a pris quatre mois avant que je
puisse mettre un pied en avant de
l'autre après l'ex no j'ai même
rechausser mes patins à led à l'arrière
grâce à l'aide et à la grande générosité
de monde par l'hospice génial designer
au nahd
c'est le poids en moins que j'ai atterri
à tant de talent atteint attendu opta
c'est à retrouver retrouver de ton
jugement tu ton raisonnement j'ai pris
conscience de laitages j'avais est pas t
elle
mais ce que s'est fixé de nouveaux rails
et des buts ambitieux comme que j'aime
que le monde doute de moi et qui me
croyais est capable de réaliser mais vu
le succès des débuts réalisa mais à
liszt je vous demande pas de croire en
moi parce que moi j'ai la certitude que
je vais essayer le plus de monde qui
m'en douter le plus de monde seront
confondus
après l'arctique équipe écrites sur moi
à 2012 dans l'abitibi express où j'ai
mentionné mon but de dépasser +14 scène
du stade de grenade
ma mère me dit ton rêve et peut-être pas
y réalise des je vais vous avouer pas
avoir été aussi bon que j'aurais voulu
lui paraissant ce tournoi là une cale
mais si je m'étais pas fixé un but assez
élevé ou s'ils vxl que je m'étais fixé
je sais vraiment pas où je suis
aujourd'hui quand je défende mes
conférences dans les écoles primaires
des gens le demandent pourquoi tu
marches au teint se trouve ta force hood
et c'est facile je marche beaucoup parce
que c'est le seul espoir qui me restent
pas retrouvé la personne que j'étais
avant puis ben ma force
la trouve dans tout le monde que qui
menace tombe et qui m'ont laissé tomber
auparavant ma faute si je trouve aussi
dans le monde qui doute de moi dans un
seul but de les faire regretter un jour
de marois d'avoir douté de moi n'ont pas
laissé tomber
depuis que j'ai évidemment content mais
j'ai réalisé la passe dans la vie tous
veulent avoir le courage de commencer et
ensuite quand le monde voit pas les
efforts pour améliorer
ils vont ancrage et puis je suis ancrage
mal ça doit être assez donné le droit de
continuer mais si j'ai mal vécu avec
l'idée de changer le monde mais les taux
change ma personnalité mes valeurs tout
en gardant ma mentalité de gagnant pour
enfin à sortir vainqueur de cette
situation là mon pauvre caché que ma
confiance en soi est inexistant ainsi
que la confiance aux eaux l'image que
les autres ont des doigts et souvent
très touchant d'inspirant qu'elle me
fait dire au jean prat ma600 teint est
plus que je son modèle c'est touchant
même que sur le coup par une petite
taille dans ma tête en me disant qu'il
avait attendu longtemps pour se trouver
un modèle
où la foi ou la faux je retournais chez
moi après les jim une madame arrête pour
ma framerate que j'ai refusée bien
évidemment pour qu'elle commence ainsi
que le veut pas et de moi aussi passé
afin pas ses mots mal à g kg qu'un qui
brûlent les chaleurs toutes ces belles
paroles viennent avec une certaine
pression que je m'inflige moment je sais
que le jour où je vais arrêter de me
bats plein de critiques vont faire
surface
en même temps ils m'abordent massat et
aujourd'hui il ya toujours des gens pour
une crise qui je parlais du mans l2
-lorient tantôt est certain c'est
peut-être parce que ça veut dire mais
oui dans la vie je fais pas face à des
problèmes mais je fais face à des défis
je vous parlais aussi d'une bière ou
tout début vous magar a commencé la
saison 2001 puis pour ceux qui pensaient
que le canada l'épaule parce qu'ils
avaient un jour trop trop pour ça les
soldats à la gare moi je n'avais que 13
% de chances de vivre la vie que je mène
aujourd'hui et je ne le changerai pour
rien au monde
à tous ces gens je vous disais c'est
d'avoir une cravate dsp et de vous
accrocher à bourail merci bonsoir
merci